and the Democratic presidential race a
candidate who did not participate in the
Iowa New Hampshire contest is getting
new criticism this morning former New
York City Mayor Mike Bloomberg who has
been rising in the national polls is
also skipping the next two battles in
Nevada and in South Carolina he's
focusing on the fourteen states that
will vote on Super Tuesday which by the
way is March 3rd ed O'Keefe is covering
campaign 2020 and joins us with the
latest on this so ed do you think this
new scrutiny is going to affect Mayor
Bloomberg strategy well we'll see recent
national polls show Bloomberg in third
behind senator Bernie Sanders and former
Vice President Joe Biden as he works to
court Asian black and Latino voters he's
facing criticism for policies he once
supported that have disproportionately
targeted minorities I am running to
defeat Donald Trump campaigning in
Tennessee former New York Mayor Mike
Bloomberg was asked about comments he
made in 2015 about stop and frisk a
policy his city once used that allowed
police officers to temporarily detain
people they considered suspicious mr.
mayor why did you say what you said in
that 2015 speech
I don't think those words reflect what
how I led the most diverse city in the
nation and apologized for the practice
and the pain that it caused Bloomberg's
also under fire for saying in 2008 that
the mortgage crisis was in part due to
the rollback of redlining or when banks
didn't lend to people under a certain
income bracket that predominantly
affected minorities Congress got
involved as local elected officials as
well and said oh that's not fair these
people should be able to get credit
Bloomberg's campaign says he fought
against the practices mayor and in a
statement noted that he now has a plan
to help a million more black families
buy a house and to counteract the
effects of redlining Bloomberg is
spending hundreds of millions of his own
money mostly in the 14 states voting on
March 3rd I think it speaks to the
corruption of our political system where
somebody who is worth 60 billion dollars
can avoid going into Iowa New Hampshire
Nevada South Carolina and as he rises in
the polls he's quickly becoming a target
of his opponents like Bernie Sanders all
he has to do is spend hundreds and
hundreds of millions of dollars on TV
ads to my mind that is not called
democracy when I spoke with senator
Sanders yesterday I asked him about
Bloomberg's comments on stop and frisk
and he said he would deal with that when
Bloomberg appears with him on a debate
stage the former mayor has yet to appear
at a debate but might by the end of the
month thanks to new party rules heed
thank you very much